[Musique]
j'aime la vie ici ça me rend vraiment
sereine mouche si vous n'êtes pas
originaire du coin non j'ai pris ma
retraite c'était quoi va jobs
j'étais dans les pompes funèbres
comme vous le savez nous contrôlons les
pensions de retraite de nos anciens
employés dans l'éventualité où nos
agents moeurs
une clause de leur contrat indique que
nous restons bénéficiaires exclusifs
c'est une mauvaise idée beck
il est au plus tard quelqu'un voulu me
piéger les vaudrait mieux tu es rien à
voir là temps vous avez essayé de faire
tuer le black kaiser et vous kidnappé sa
jolie voisine
[Musique]
qui paye et le héron sera pas obligé de
regarder derrière nous le restant de nos
jours
tu va avoir besoin de tout ça essaye de
contenir tu as peur tu fais des erreurs
quand apple n'avait pas arrêté de fumer
je me suis dit que j'en aurai pas
[Musique]
pourquoi tu fais tout ça
je les aime bien
c'est pas le type idéal
pour faire du bien là où tu passes
est ce que par hasard vous auriez
remarqué quelque chose de bizarre près
de chez vous
non